hi
guys so last year I stood here and we
showed you a video of this crazy game
we're making called No Man's sky this
year I guess I really just wanted to
show you how it
plays so this is a giant sandbox that
we're making a Universe siiz
Sandbox it's full of
choices like here we're at the boundary
between two Waring
factions I could join in I could take
sides
so that's a tiny glimpse of space
combat uh but I've only got three
minutes and there's loads that I want to
show you like this so this is the solar
system that we're currently at that's
where that battle is taking place but
battles like that are taking place
across the
universe if I pull back a little
bit you could see the other stars nearby
that I can reach with my current
hyperdrive and I'm going to pull back a
little bit more to give you a sense of
the size of the game but when I do I
really need you to keep in mind to
understand that every one of these
points of light is a sun and every one
of those Suns has its own solar system
with planet-sized planets orbiting
around it those have life
[Music]
ecology and I could even go a little
faster now most of these places have
never been visited many of them never
will
be over there in the distance is the
center of the Galaxy that's where we're
all trying to get
to and I'm going to do something really
stupid I just going to pick one of these
at
[Music]
random and we can go
there now this was okay in rehearsal
otherwise it wouldn't be here but uh if
anything horrible goes wrong just keep
in mind that I've not been here
before
cool
so here we are in an Undiscovered solar
system probably no one's ever been here
before I can do a
scan and when I do you'll see some
points of interest that red one down
there is a
beacon and I've made it so that there's
always a beacon near where I warp in
Just For
This
so beacons are where
you beacons are where you upload
discoveries that's it over there behind
that
rock um and this is the planet that
we've just found this an alien world
that we've found together this is planet
E3
and it's not like the prettiest Planet
I've seen better uh but I've also seen a
lot
worse uh so I could do a
scan
and uh as luck would have it there's no
alien life uh but I can show you this so
every planet in every solar system is
fully
destructible
those guys are the
Sentinels they protect the planets from
explorers like
me oh and now I'm underwat and there's
fish there a V3
fish cool so now I need to find that
Beacon uh and I can upload those
discoveries
[Music]
so now when the game is out and we'll
announce a release date soon I promise
when the game is out one of you might
one day come across this
planet that's just a little glimpse of
No Man's Sky it's got trading fighting
exploring
survival and it's a huge
game thank
you